♫ Big Gary V up in the office
♫ Do rag flapping
♫ Talks about all the shift and leverage
♫ 1,800 checks to shout out the beverage
- [Man] So I think you need like.
- [Man] I do think that.
- I think we need everyone to have.
But if it were.
- I'm cramping.
You know, when there's a function,
it's, that I like a
lot, that I like a lot.
Alright, thank you, good start.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Hi, how are you?
- [Woman] I'm good, how are you?
- [Greg] Kelsey, real pleasure.
I'll be right with you.
- [Woman] No worries.
- [Greg] I just need a few minutes.
- I finally feel like I'm
truly in the right place
and time where I should be professionally,
and like this is where I want to be,
and I truly feel at home in this company.
- Like literally you're
going to send me an email.
I'm going to ask you to send me an email,
which I'm going to use as my to do list,
and it's literally going to be, you know,
I'm literally going to
go get all your feedback,
like speak to Claude, speak
to Steve, speak to Jason,
and see if there's something
I can help you with.
- [Woman] That would
be amazing, seriously.
- [Man] You sore?
- I'm not sore, I'm cramping
in the middle of my back,
which is not allowing me to function.
Would love to just get us all aligned
on what our strategy is,
and see what we can get done.
So what has happened since we last met?
♫ It's a complicated business
♫ And the feelings come and go
- [Greg] I apologize, one minute.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- An outrage.
- Give you an update on the team,
also to kind of like start having
a high level discussion
just on like going.
- The industry, the state of the union.
- Going forward.
Yeah, what do we want to be doing?
- In parallel, it is an industry
that is going to be massive
and will continue.
Nothing's changed from
my level of my belief,
and you know it's interesting.
I was in Hong Kong.
They're called KOLs there,
key opinion leaders.
The KOL market in China
and Asia is out of control.
- [Man] It's huge, it's
their number one media.
They don't even buy media.
- Because the platforms own everything
and because everything is tip based,
so like all the influencers
are getting like tips
while they live chat.
I really want you deeply focused on this
because I know it's going to happen.
That I know I'm right about.
In the same way that I knew I was right
about social media ads,
I believe that VaynerMedia
wins two obnoxious media AORs
on the back of our disproportionate truth
that we understand influencer
marketing better than.
And I believe that we can make the market
fully believe that in
2022 and that's smart.
Cool?
- [Man] Cool.
- Thank you. - [Woman] Hi.
- [Greg] How are you?
- [Woman] Great to meet you.
- Such a pleasure, I'll be right with you.
The way to really win is
to have a pillar, right?
Book is a pillar, but
it's a historic pillar.
To me a new age pillar is either a vlog
or a podcast and you should
have one or the other.
- [Woman] Okay.
- Period.
- Like to me, ironically, actually this is
the first time I'm saying this.
To me, ironically, if you do
not have a vlog or a podcast
right now, you're just
leaving an enormous amount
of opportunity, to me, you
know I guess I'm hedging,
but to me it's you become vulnerable
to not being relevant.
Like you need to have
both of them, one of them,
or you need to be an actual celebrity.
Like to me it's the only thing that equals
having a television show
or being an actor, actress,
or like it's a pillar.
- My spoken word kind
of stuff has really been
the one thing that these
kids, no matter where I go,
freak out over, so a lot of
people have been telling me
to just do a lot of videos for that,
post it on Instagram,
YouTube, and all of that,
and again with the quality,
I'm just, I'm working.
- [Greg] That's why you're struggling.
- Okay.
- You put quality, your
personal subjective quality
on a pedestal.
It is such a cliche
reason people struggle.
You're going to have to jump into the pool
and just see what happens,
in the same way that at a macro level,
writing the book itself,
you've got to basically do
the same thing with social.
There's no piece of content
with bad enough lighting,
with bad enough quality, with like,
there's no piece of content
that's going to take you down.
- Great.
- Such a pleasure.
- [Woman] Yes.
- Have a great day.
- Thank you, can I take
a picture with you?
- Sure, of course.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- [Woman] Hi Greg.
- Hi.
- I feel like there's a lot of
exciting things happening now
and I feel like I want to make sure
that I'm being smart about
short term helping the company,
long term working towards my goal.
- Good for you.
- You know I'm turning
30 in a week and a half
and that just sparks a lot
of thoughts and feelings.
- 100%.
- [Woman] I'm so acutely
aware the next couple years
can make a huge difference.
- Yeah, that's probably right.
- [Woman] How I use my time
and what I do in this time.
- I would tell you a couple of things
as someone who's 41.
That is right,
and shockingly always right.
Like there are so many people
that are 57 years old right now,
have misplayed it in their own
mind and other people's minds
for the last, you know 37 years,
and legitimately can
make a decision tomorrow
that makes the next 30 years
of their life so fruitful
that it covers the warts
of the prior 40 years.
I genuinely know that to be true,
so you're right, but I
think it's imperative
that you don't cripple yourself
that there's this magical 36 month window
between 30 and 33, that
if you play it right,
you go on to have this incredible life
and if you don't you
have a fraction of it.
There's absolute truth to that.
There's also equal non truth to it
if you decide to make a decision at 33.
Instead of tripling down on
the right career decisions,
I would argue that one of the best things
you can do for you to really win
is developing an off speed pitch
to your normal demeanor
that allows you to have,
it's unbelievable how
much comfort I have in,
I'm content while still hungrier
than anything I've ever even seen.
That's fucking balance.
♫ I realized that I never even knew
♫ Your middle name
♫ I realized that summer's over
♫ It was my time
♫ To go away
- Binders, books, and I
just sit in front of my TV
watching the draft, the NFL draft.
- [Man] Who'd you like growing up?
You did?
- My dream was to be the general manager
of the New York Jets.
My dream was to be the
first GM since 69 to.
- [Man] Win a Super Bowl?
- Manager for the Jets.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Hello.
Hello gang, how are you, how are things?
I used to sell lemonade,
as you guys probably know,
and one time a guy on a bike.
I will never forget this story,
stops and has like a classic
old school 1980s water bottle,
so just a plastic water bottle,
and he goes fill this up
and I'll give you $10.
And it was probably
$1.25 worth of lemonade
if you measured it.
I don't think he even got to
fill this up and I'll give you.
I think he said, by the
time he was done with up,
I had it fully filled up, and that $10,
to this day, I've never had a transaction,
million, multi million dollar transactions
never felt like that, to this day.
So I get that $34 day.
I have one.
It's a $10 fill up and it feels better
than anything I've ever done
in my life professionally.
And so how's it going
right now with culture?
- [Man] It's fun, I feel fine with it
and I feel a couple
locations I can manage.
It just gets to a point where I feel like
I'm just not there that often.
- Okay, so that's the big punchline?
Like you feel, from afar, that you like
are intrigued by how
much I care about that
and talk about that and it
seems like right to you?
- [Man] Yeah, and I've
seen competitors fall
when they've had that problem.
- Got it.
So look, here's a couple core things.
Number one, you can't
control anything at scale.
The way you control it is at a macro,
so here's what I mean by that.
A couple things that I
think will stand out.
Number one, you have to fire people
that undermine the culture that you want,
regardless of what they do.
If you end up having 11 locations
and the regional manager,
because that's the way
you decided to structure,
she or he has five stores
under their watch and their stores
are doing the best financially,
but you know that she's either changed
or it's been exposed that he can't manage
the people anymore, you
have to fire that person.
The biggest reason people lose on culture
is they value the money the
person brings to the table
over the undermining that that
person's creating to culture.
It's as simple as that.
I think the number one
way to make culture great
is to use a parenting analogy.
Parents that really
dominate do the following.
There's a thing.
Ricky's going to a new high school,
we have to pick the high school.
Sally wants to go to sleep
away camp, which one?
We don't like Sally's new boyfriend, Rick.
Like all that shit, right?
What great parents do is
they go into the bedroom,
fucking duke it the fuck out,
and then walk out of
that room united front
and there's no veering from the narrative.
I did a great job with
that at Wine Library.
I did a good job with it at Vayner,
and then I did a bad job of it.
What I never told Steve
or the people of his level
and higher was no friction among us 50
and that's why there's
a lot to fix for Vayner,
in my opinion, because
every single leader here
blindly needs to support
every other leader
and then hash it out and then
use me as the Supreme Court
because they may not be
able to get to a resolution,
but then they can come to
me and I make decisions
and then they have to blindly support that
or they can leave if
they hate my decision.
- [Man] We're working on everything,
we're starting the music right now,
but I'm recording things, but I don't feel
like they're as good
as they're going to be
six months from now when I'm
really ready to put it out,
but I still want to start,
I still would like to start.
- I would put it out.
- [Man] Put it out anyway?
- I would put it out anyway,
but I would put it out anyway
under that pretext.
So for example, you've got
to be smart with strategy.
Maybe you call it Alpha,
Alpha Music colon, and then you just put
the title of the song.
And people are like what
the fuck is Alpha Music?
Like you literally just, like
we literally just made it up.
It's Alpha Music.
It's now that we're in
the world of journey,
of documenting the journey,
and I know my music
is going to get substantially better,
this is music I'm making.
I'd like you to hear it, I
want to document my journey,
but I'd like to call it Alpha Music
because it's not ready for prime time.
Who says you can't?
I like this one.
By the way, this is why I document
because I feel like that's just a really,
like I feel like that's what I would do
if I was doing it, right?
(upbeat instrumental music)
You guys ready?
- [Group] Yeah.
- [Gary] One minute.
- [Man] That's all we need.
- Good.
- Hey, I'm Joe Harris.
- My name is Juan Alsavar.
- My name is Ewan Vernet.
- My name is Daniel Fessler.
- Alright, so we're needing
capital, right, to start this?
What's in it for me is the questions.
You're in a branding speed game.
Give the bill a brand.
The end.
- He heard me, he
understood, and let's go.
I'm ready to go earn some money
and let's rock it right now.
- [Woman] Awesome.
- Let's go.
- It went better than
I could have expected.
We're ready to, you know, go forward.
- He's always providing
a wealth of knowledge
and giving us all these
little tidbits of advice.
- Now one thing that I love about Gary V
is that he keeps it real
and he offers real solutions
that you can apply to
your business immediately.
- Making a better video
that doesn't have it
in the three seconds versus a worse video
that does have it in three seconds
will most likely sell more cups
of coffee or wine, I think.
- [Man] It does and it doesn't.
There's a lot of different
variables at play.
- Go ahead, I mean like
this is the conversation
I want to have, you know what I mean.
Why don't we watermark
the logo of every brand
in every video?
Why don't we put a ticker at the bottom?
Why don't we invent the
ticker for videos on Facebook
the way ESPN or CNBC or
whoever fucking invented.
Someday some gal or guy
sat in a room like this
and said let's make a fucking ticker.
There was no tickers in 1972.
Andy, I want to create, you
know how ESPN has a ticker?
I want every video that I
make for the next six months
to have a ticker.
- Socials, everything?
- I don't know.
I now only put out videos with tickers.
Let everybody start designing.
That is my new thing.
I'm now the ticker guy.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- [Man] Three, two, one.
- Can you give me five seconds?
- Sure, sure.
- To walk with you.
- Ready?
Let's go.
- Take care, have a good night.
- [Gary] Take care, guys.
(upbeat instrumental music)